we turn it up tonight no how about Jamie
Lee Curtis up there you know she was
giving her speech and I'm like oh my God
she texts you back yeah of course
and maybe Sharon will be texting Austin
Butler later cameras caught the pair
exchanging numbers outside the Vanity
Fair party before waving the fans and
who's that walking by Austin's ex
Vanessa Hudgens giving him a glance and
moving on
arrived with girlfriend Kaia Gerber and
check out newly engaged Jon Hamm with
co-star Anna Osceola showing off her
emerald cut engagement ring also
apparently ready to say I do Justin long
and Kate Bosworth and rebel congrats on
your engagement
Yep this bash was date night
were you listening to Ari today were you
getting ready yes we were loving the new
hair color by the way it looks so good
[Music]
hey Adam what about Blake leaving The
Voice man it's about time you miss him
Joshua Jackson and Jody Turner Smith
ended rumors of relationship troubles
with this moment but not so sure about
Megan Fox who posed without MGK Haley
Bieber posed solo before meeting up with
Justin inside and over at Elton John's
annual Oscar party the host was eager to
take some time off his farewell tour
I've got 50 more shows to do in Europe
which will bring me to 329 in total and
then I'm gonna go on a vacation with my
family for two months this is like the
one night of the year where we don't go
to bed at nine o'clock so yeah yeah
while Cheryl Burt opened up about the
Revelation that she was almost The
Bachelorette it was meetings like we we
were about to do this thing it wasn't
meant to be because obviously it didn't
happen hey I'm still looking for love so
[Music]
thank you